sí buenos días a la la digamos las
declaraciones de ayer de henrique
capriles lo que hacen es fracturar más a
la oposición ya venía fragmentada antes
de que juan guaidó se convirtiera en
líder opositor en enero del 2019 son
cuatro las personas que durante los
últimos años son las caras visibles de
la oposición que son juan guaidó
leopoldo los que están unidos en esta
idea del cese al usurpación que no ha
funcionado hasta el momento tan primaria
corina machado que es de las que opina
que deben venir fuerzas extranjeras al
país para sacar a nicolás maduro y ahora
de jett aprile que es el que está de
parte de asistir a las elecciones
legislativas en diciembre para como dice
el entrar por una brecha y ganar
espacios al gobierno de nicolás maduro
todos tienen y de pintas sacar quienes
sacarán con las maduras pero no llega a
un acuerdo juan guaidó ha dicho esta
semana que presentar al país su
propuesta de una y la oposición pese a
esta nueva idea que ha propuesto
prefiere luchar a no luchar como le dije
antes que quiere aprovechar esta brecha
para entrar de alguna manera a la
asamblea nacional y también tienes que
aprovechar la oportunidad de que el
gobierno llamado luego de 14 años a la
unión europea y al lado y al a la onu
para que participen como observadores
internacionales en estas elecciones de
diciembre habrá que esperar estos
próximos días que faltan pocos
y poco tiempo para que se pueda
inscribir las personas para estas
elecciones a ver si realmente la
posición va a seguir lo que capriles ha
decidido el día de ayer bien pues muchas
gracias por tu reporte herminia